at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking so now I also you posted a
question now it is
[Music]
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by LegalZoom which more
than 2 million Americans have used to
help start their businesses past guests
even such as well WordPress lead
developer CEO of automatic Matt
Mullenweg now valued at more than a
billion dollars have used LegalZoom to
help with their business needs
specifically in his case to form his
company but LegalZoom isn't just for
launching your business their services
include everything from helping you to
manage changing tax laws reviewing
contracts creating NDA's non-disclosure
agreements important stuff handling
lease agreements and assisting with
really any other legal challenge hurdle
inconvenience that typically takes time
and effort away from running your
business the best part is that you won't
get charged by the hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get a la carte style
so visit legalzoom.com and check out
their business section for all their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lower case I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him
this episode is brought to you by linked
in if you're looking for a job knowing
where to look is the first step towards
finding the right fit
LinkedIn has more than 20 million job
postings from software engineer to
robotics engineer project manager to HR
manager or associate attorney to
associate veterinarian there's something
for everybody
they have everything it also has one of
the largest communities to help you
connect and network with people who can
open doors for you give you valuable
career advice help you learn new skills
and introduce you to people at companies
and organizations that are hiring
companies and organizations that are
looking for exactly your skill set and
no matter where you are in your career
whether you're just starting out
wondering what to do switching to a new
type of role or completely starting over
and no matter what job you're looking
for there are people on LinkedIn who can
help you find it with more than 20
million jobs posted there's a good
chance that LinkedIn has exactly what
you're looking for you just have to
check it out so find the job meant for
you at linkedin.com forward slash jobs
again that's linkedin.com forward slash
jobs my name is jacque a wink i spent 20
years in the military more specifically
in the Navy and even more specifically
than that I was in the SEAL Teams for my
whole career I started off as an
enlisted SEAL eventually I moved up
through the ranks and became a seal
officer and I deployed around the world
and I was lucky enough to deploy to Iraq
a couple of times the first time as I
see old platoon commander and then as
the commander of the SEAL Team three
task unit bruiser during the Battle of
Ramadi in 2006 and when I got back from
that deployment I took over the advanced
training for the West Coast SEAL Teams
as my final assignment in the Navy and
after I retired I started a leadership
consulting company called national
enfant which led me to writing a bunch
of books for
for adults and then a bunch of books for
kids as well and you can get those books
whatever books are sold and along the
way with some coaxing from mr. Tim
Ferriss and mr. Joe Rogan after being on
their podcasts I started my own podcast
called jaakko podcast which comes out on
Wednesdays every week and I talk about
human nature through the lens of war and
atrocities and leadership and I would be
sitting down with Tim right now but he's
off in the jungle or the desert or the
mountains somewhere so I am just going
to answer your questions this time by
myself so thanks to Tim for having me on
again and thanks to you all for
listening and here we go the first
question is from an anonymous person how
did you meet your wife and other tips on
building a family so I met my wife when
I was overseas my wife happened to be
overseas at the same time and when I saw
her I was I was I was kind of taken
aback by my by my wife because she was a
stunning looking woman and I walked
right up to her and immediately said you
know started talking to her and I won't
go into the gory details of that whole
situation but because I because I asked
my wife if I could tell the whole story
and she actually said do not do that so
I'm not going to but I met my when I met
her I went up talked to her and not only
was she stunningly beautiful she was
also super nice which was a very nice
surprise for me and immediately I told
one of my buddies a couple days later
that I was gonna marry that girl if I
could and we ended up yes getting
married the the tips I have on this I
would say well first of all tell you
that getting married is probably the
most important decision that you're
gonna make in your life because you're
gonna end up spending your rest of your
life with this other human being which
which is a big task and so you really
want to make a good decision and and of
course there's a dichotomy in this too
because if you think you're gonna find
the perfect wife you you're not or you
think you're gonna find the perfect
husband you're not they don't exist no
one's perfect everyone's gonna have
their little idiosyncrasies about them
that you don't like or that bother you
and so what you have to do is you have
to find somebody that you know has
idiosyncrasies that don't bother you
very much the other thing and I would
say I got lucky in this I would love to
tell you that I was at was a visionary
and knew exactly what I was looking for
but I didn't I got lucky and just
happened to meet this this woman that
had this quality which I believe is very
important and that is that my wife was
emotionally stable and emotionally
independent and so what I mean by that
is my wife wasn't always relying on me
emotionally to give her support about
things she didn't really this sounds bad
but she really need me you know I didn't
need to be there and and trust me when
you're in the SEAL Teams you're not
there a lot so I I think if you can find
someone that's emotionally independent
that doesn't rely on you to prop them up
every day I think that's a big benefit
and of can someone go too far with that
yeah cuz I'm sure you could have someone
that's so independent that they don't
even want to be around you and that
would be a problem so but I think we
tend towards people we like the feeling
of someone that's depending on us and
and so I think we I think I saw guys get
sucked into that over the years so I
think you look for someone that's got a
little bit of emotional independence
that they can stand on their own and
then and then when it comes to just
relationship and I don't know you might
want to check yourself if you're coming
to me for relationship advice but you
are so I'll put it out to you the here's
the here's the thing when and I have
been married for a long time 20 plus
years that's a pretty long time to be
married
I guess these days well one of the
things going back to the idea of extreme
ownership is guess what you take
ownership of your relationship and you
take ownership of the problems inside
your relationship if you're blaming your
spouse when things
go wrong that's not gonna work out
really well
and when I try to think of an examples
talking about this with someone the
other day and want one example that when
my kids were younger it's always
stressful stressful time in the family
is getting ready for school in the
morning you got kids you got teeth to
get brushed you got lunches to get made
you got the clock is ticking you're
gonna be late there's traffic there's
all these things going on and so
sometimes you can that that stress can
start to impact negatively the family so
I was thinking what's the situation
where you've got to take ownership well
let's say normally you know for me I was
getting up and going to work my wife was
getting up and getting the kids ready
for school
cool those are our two jobs in the
morning I get ready to go to work she
gets ready to take kids school so let's
say the lunches weren't made and the
kids got up late my wife got up late and
all of a sudden she can't get out the
door cuz she's got to make make the
sandwiches for the kids and if I look at
her and say well you know you didn't
make the sandwiches that's why
everyone's late I'm telling you right
now that's not gonna work out well
you're blaming the person and when you
blame people they get defensive and they
start blaming other things and they're
gonna blame you and they're gonna blame
the kids they're to blame everyone else
so that doesn't solve the problem all it
does is create arguments so instead of
doing that what you do is you take
ownership just like when you're in a in
a seal platoon or you're in a business
when something goes wrong you take
ownership of the problem so if instead
of saying hey you didn't make the lunges
that's why everyone's late instead you
say hey you know what I notice everyone
was a little bit late today tomorrow you
know I think I can help out by getting
up a little bit earlier and making the
lunches and well realistically and with
my wife my wife would be you know my
wife would say back to me no that's fine
you got to go to work I slept in I
shouldn't have done that so so it
immediately reverses the defensive
attitude of what are you talking about I
didn't make the lunches why am i making
lunches it turns it into oh you know
what no you have to go to work I'm gonna
get up and make it's my fault
I'll take care of it and and that's
that's a great solution right that
that's problem solved and then people
worry about it because they say what
what if i if i said that to my wife you
don't my wife would say they say yeah
you should get up and make the lunches
and then you know what I say get up and
make the lunches it's gonna take you an
extra it takes take six minutes six
minutes to get the lunches made probably
not even that so no big deal get up a
little earlier get up six minutes
earlier actually make the lunch the
night before and and it'll be fine and
eventually most likely your wife is
gonna say hey you know what you need to
make the bunches I'll do it I got it
so that's what you do that's what you do
you just like in any other leadership
situation or even in a peer driven
situation what you do is you take
ownership when you take ownership of
things life gets better give it a shot
that's the first question next question
is from AB far and the question is
what's Jacko's criteria about when you
should quit and when to persevere in
areas with opportunity costs like
businesses so this is a definitely a
very good question especially if you
know anything about the SEAL Teams one
of the mottos of the SEAL Teams is never
quit and I should say that's really more
of a motto of the basic SEAL training
that you go through the Budds training
the the first block of training that you
go through when you when you join the
Navy to be a seal at six months long and
and the the underlying mantra there is
don't quit and of course it actually
makes very good sense in training in
that training because that's how you
make it through the training you don't
quit and people people
I'll get kids that ask me nowadays you
know I want to go on I'm not gonna go to
the SEAL Teams I want to go and through
SEAL training what advice do you have
for man sir I was telling the same thing
over and over again don't quit that's
that's how you get through the training
don't quit so going through that
training it makes sense but I'll tell
you once you get to the actual SEAL
Teams you have to take that attitude and
you have to put it in some kind of
perspective because that attitude can be
bad and the classic example of that is
the young leader the young seal leader
who comes up with a plan for a training
mission
but maybe it's not the best plan or
maybe the circumstances change or
something unexpected happens or the
weather or the terrain isn't what wasn't
anticipated and the plan is not working
that's what's going on the plant
whatever plan they came up with is not
working but that young leader has been
told never quit
so he keeps going and he keeps going and
he keeps going and he keeps going and he
uses up all his energy and all his time
and all his resources and all of his
people because he had been taught never
quit so that is actually wrong and you
don't do that if you are trying
something and you have given it a solid
effort and it's not working then stop
doing it and step back and assess and
see if there's another way to do it that
is not quitting that is being smart I
have a little rule I say don't bang my
head into something 47 times I'll do 46
once you get to 46 then it's like okay
you know what I gotta try a different
way this is not working so sometimes you
have to step back you have to you have
to quit the plan that you had and try
something new now the other way to frame
this is by looking at it from a tactical
level and then from a strategic
perspective tactical level meaning the
immediate situation right in front of
you and the situation that's unfolding
right now in this very period of time so
like a firefight that's going on right
now or this actual battle that we're in
right now that's tactical that's what's
happening on a tactical level and then
above that is the strategic level and
this is the broad long-term overall
objective that you are trying to achieve
so those are the two different
perspectives that you can look at this
idea of when to quit
so in a war the tactical objective might
be to take a hill right we're gonna take
that hill that's our objective right now
whereas the strategic objective might be
to remove this tyrannical regime and
stop their imperialistic endeavors that
threaten your own nation-state so that's
the strategy that's what you are
strategically trying to accomplish
so now you look at those two things
right if you're assaulting this hill and
it's heavily defended and the hill is
fortified and has massive enemy troops
massive numbers of enemy troops in there
and you can't take that hill without
suffering massive catastrophic losses
yourself it's probably a good idea just
to back off the hill a little bit and
figure out another way of taking it or
figuring out if you can actually bypass
that hill see if you can avoid even
having to take that hill now that might
be considered quitting right
I'm not going up that hill I'm not gonna
lose everyone trying to get up this hill
but even though it might be considered
quitting it also could be considered
smart because why would you waste your
troops if there's another way to go
about this if there's there's the and
I'll tell you one reason that people
continue doing this is a lot of times
people will drive on a tactical mission
and the only reason that they keep going
is a because they've been told never
quit and be because their ego their ego
their ego they're gonna stick with their
plan they came up with their plan they
want their plan to work and they're
gonna go and are gonna keep going until
everyone's dead that is not smart
because if you backed off that
particular goal you could allocate your
resources and your troops somewhere else
where you might have a bigger impact so
so quitting that tactical mission that
low-level tactical mission it might not
only be acceptable it might be a
necessity because let's face it if all
you do is to attack Hills where everyone
dies you're not gonna you're gonna lose
strategically in the long run so
sometimes you gotta back off sometimes
you gotta you've got to quit that
tactical mission and there's been plenty
of times in history where that has
happened and and and people made
tactical retreats we'll call it tactical
quitting in order to win strategically
so when
when General George Washington led the
retreat of Continental forces out of New
York which was a lucky retreat because
there was this massive fog and they were
able to do it clandestinely that that
was a he quit but guess what he came
back for the strategic win in World War
one Gallipoli was some super hard
fighting there labrats the Aussies the
New Zealand troops French as well and
they had really hard fighting and
eventually they realized that this
wasn't working and they snuck away they
they retreated did they quit I guess you
could say they quit that tactical
situation and it's the same thing I mean
probably the most famous example this is
Dunkirk at the beginning of World War
two when you know this this ad-hoc
British Navy of merchant vessels and
whatever else pulled out you know
hundreds of thousands soldiers out of
Europe so that they could regroup
rebuild and re-engage so nkn by the way
come back for the win for the strategic
win of getting rid of the tyrannical
leader of Nazi Germany so was anyone
calling the Brits Kuwaitis because they
decided to save a massive number of
their troops no it's okay we have to do
a tactical retreat so yes sometimes you
have to retreat but that doesn't mean
you quit the strategic mission you know
it's like Churchill said never surrender
but he didn't say never retreat so I
think you have to do a little
differentiation between quitting and
retreating and that's that's what you
need to do and you need to do the same
thing in life right because sometimes we
come up with ideas we come up with plans
that aren't as good as we think maybe
they were and at some point you got to
look at it from an honest perspective
and see if maybe this isn't going to
work maybe we can't take that hill and
that doesn't mean you know if you come
up with one idea for a product and it
doesn't work and you decide you're gonna
retreat from it does that mean you just
never come up with another product again
when strategically what your goal was
was to build a large business or
or become financially independent or be
your own boss or whatever if you if you
back off of one tactical mission or you
quit with one product that you came up
with does that mean you're never gonna
do anything in business again no it just
means that you're gonna regroup you're
gonna reload you're gonna come up with a
better idea and then you're gonna do it
you're gonna attack again
you're gonna keep that strategic vision
alive so I think that's it I think to
sum this up that's kind of a long answer
I apologize to sum this up you might
have to make some tactical retreats in
order to win the long war but never quit
on your strategic vision never quit on
getting to the ultimate place where you
want to go the next question is from
Brendan and the question is how does
discipline pay a role in financial
decisions on two levels
macro slash investing and micro meaning
daily and monthly budgets how has this
changed recently
well discipline equals freedom as you
may have heard me said they say the
first time I was on Tim's podcast if in
the example that in this situation is if
you want financial freedom you need
financial discipline so what does that
mean that means you have to work hard
you have to save your money you have to
invest your money you have to not buy
stupid things that you don't need I
often give the example of my 1997 Dodge
Grand Caravan kind of rusted broken
window on the driver's side that was
taped shut but I drove that vehicle for
I don't know ten or twelve years and the
reason I did is because I was saving
money I also lived in a house that was
934 square feet it had two bedrooms and
I had three kids two girls and a boy and
my wife and my wife and I slept in the
living room and when you opened the
front door to our house to the right was
a couch and to the left was our bed and
that's where we slept and right next to
our bed was the dining room table
so like our front room of our house was
the bedroom dining room and living room
all
all in one big room zero privacy but
that's where we left why do we live
there because it was in a location that
we liked and we were saving money I
pretty much always wore the same clothes
my guys used to give me a hard time
because I would wear jungle boots out on
Liberty with my normal clothes
why cuz I'm not gonna go out and buy
some pair of fashionable shoes I caught
my own hair so I have a pair of clippers
that I've had forever and I cut my own
hair so that's the discipline that I
think put you in a good place later on
in life when you save money up front and
so now when we talk about macro
investing what do I do now I like to put
my money into well actually into my
businesses and it's things that I own
things that I control things that I know
about and so I do that and I like to buy
properties so I invest of investment
properties and in Ana I take other
opportunities if there's something that
I have an understanding of some business
opportunity then I'll put my money in
that I will said I do have a nicer car
now I no longer drive the 1997 Dodge
Grand Caravan may she rest in peace
I also instill a little bit I still even
though I have more money now I still am
a person that struggles to spend money
on things and I will research some
stupid purchase for three months to
figure out if it's something that I
really need to figure out if it's the
actual one that I want and all that so
so there you go I I guess on a macro
thing I look to buy big things or I look
to invest in big things like properties
and businesses and on the micro I look
to buy nothing I don't want it I don't
need it and I'm trying not to buy it so
there's that next question is from Joey
and he says how do you balance your time
as a father with your business podcast
workouts and then there's a follow-on
question what values do you hope to pass
on to your children so this is a
question that everyone wants the secret
answer to and you
how do you balance your time with your
family versus your time with work and
the answer is that that is the answer
you have to balance it so what do i do
yes do I wake up early I do I wake up
really do I stay up late yes I do I try
and do things before and after my family
is awake or before that or after they
fall asleep so that I'm I'm working when
they're sleeping which seems to work out
well in terms of trying to spend more
time with them in like in the morning in
the morning I'll wake up early and work
out so that way when they're when they
get up and they're eating their
breakfast wherever I can say hi to him
and talk to him a little bit I also try
and do things that are that are mutually
beneficial to everyone to all of us so
for instance I like to do things with my
wife and kids like work out together or
do jujitsu together or wrestle or surf I
like to do things that that I like to do
and that they like to do too so that
seems to do a good job of spending more
time with the family I I don't always do
a great job of this I have missed some
pretty critical events with my kids
because of work and that's a sad reality
I've missed some some pretty big events
because I've had things that I had to do
I had commitments I had contractual
obligations that I couldn't get out of
and so would miss and you know I've
missed some pretty important things for
my kids and I definitely feel bad about
that and I'll say this though they also
learn from that because when they see
that I am doing that I'm doing putting a
big placing a big importance on work
they realize that work is important they
realize that you have to be dedicated to
your work they see me up early working
they see me staying up late working and
they know from seeing that that if they
want to get anywhere there's going to be
sacrifices that have to get made so
that's it I I also often explained this
to people you know you you get a job and
you work hard so that you can earn money
so that you can take care of your family
and that being said if you focus too
much on working hard and too much on
your job well then eventually if you
look up you'll look at your family they
won't be there anymore because you
weren't paying enough attention to them
so you you can't let that happen
the other end of the spectrum is you're
trying to take care of your family so
you're trying to spend all your time
with your family which means you stop
paying attention to work like you should
and instead of going through the meeting
you're at you know the parent-teacher
conference and instead of going to the
the networking event at your company
you're you're going to the recital for
your you know six-year-olds piano and
eventually you look up and you realize
that you're not where you want to be
work wise and maybe you're getting let
go maybe you're not promoting the way
you want to so that's not good either so
that's why as I said to kick this off
the the key is balance you have to find
the balance on these things if you focus
too much on work you won't have a family
if you focus too much on family you
won't have work so get balanced the
second part of this question was what
values do I hope to pass on to my kids I
think the values that are trying to pass
on to my kids are pretty much the
standard kind of human values and to be
really simple about how to discuss this
well I wrote I wrote multiple kids books
trying to pass on the values that I
think are important for kids the first
book that I wrote for kids was called
way the warrior kid and the the first
book is about a kid who's kind of having
that same normal problems that every kid
has he's can't do any pull-ups he
doesn't know how to swim he doesn't know
his times tables and he's getting picked
on at school and what happens is kind of
last day at school he's all sad and
bummed out and he gets called out for
not being able to do any pull-ups and
not knowing how to swim and he runs
behind the librarian he's crying and
eventually heads home from his last day
of school and then he remembers that his
uncle Jake is coming to stay with him
for the summertime and his uncle Jake
was in the SEAL Teams and his uncle Jake
when they when he shows up you know they
start talking and he says hey you know
what do you want to do tomorrow you want
to go you want to go play some ball you
want to go for a swim and he says then
the kid whose name is Mark says well you
know I can't I can't swim and I don't
know my times table I'm getting picked
on and I can't do any pull-ups he starts
crying and Uncle Jake looks at him and
says hey listen all these problems that
you've got they can be solved and then
they go on the the mission over the
summer of working out eating right
learning how to study learning jujitsu
learning how to swim overcoming his fear
of water all those things happen and one
of the parts that's embedded in the
story is that Uncle Jake talks about how
warriors live by a code and he
encourages young mark to write his own
warrior kid code and in that warrior kid
code I pretty much passed forth of the
values that I try and give to my kids
and so here's the warrior kid code from
the book way the warrior kid the number
one the warrior kid wakes up early in
the morning the warrior kids studies to
learn and gain knowledge and asks
questions if he doesn't understand the
warrior kid trains hard exercises and
eats right to be strong and fast and
healthy the warrior kid trains to know
how to fight so he can stand up to
bullies and protect the weak the warrior
kid treats people with respect doesn't
judge them and helps out other people
whenever possible the warrior kid keeps
things neat and is always prepared and
ready for action
the warrior kid stays humble controls
his ego and stays calm warrior kids do
not lose their tempers the warrior kid
works hard saves money is frugal and
doesn't waste things and always does his
best I am the warrior kid and I am
leader so that's the warrior kid code
and that warrior kid code that's
actually the one that I just read is
from the third book in the series
because each book young mark adds a
little something to the warrior kid Cody
adds he learns a life lesson and then he
adds it to his warrior kid code and so
that's those the values that I try and
pass on it and that's I also I also do a
kid's podcast called the warrior kid
podcast and what the funnest part I've
had with that warrior kid podcast cuz it
started off me just doing questions for
Uncle Jake and then I would answer the
questions and kid which kids would say
is is pepperoni healthy and so I'd
answer these great questions from these
kids and but eventually what I started
doing is I started telling stories from
Uncle Jake where uncle Jake would talk
about where he was a kid or when when he
was a kid and they would kind of capture
some important lesson that he learned
and they're all just kind of parable
stories that again back to this question
teach the values that I think kids
should have and that's the what the
stories do the stories are meant to
explain where uncle Jake got his values
from so yeah those are the warrior kid
podcast if you want to check that out
and the warrior kid books all right next
question
and it says I'd like to hear his
thoughts on sexual harassment toxic
masculinity and then it says I am
working to teach my son's about matters
like consent okay so I know this has
been a big big topic toxic masculinity
and I'm not a psychologist certainly I
don't claim to be you know some somebody
that understands everything but you know
what I have spent a lot of time around
alpha males so I spent 20 years in the
SEAL Teams and there's a lot of alpha
male type human beings in there I have
my own son so I have a decent
understanding of the male human I also
like I said I've been married for 21
years
and I have three daughters by the way
one of them's 19 one of them's 18 and
one of them is nine that that counteract
the testosterone of my sixteen-year-old
son to the best of their ability but my
point is I I have some experience with
both sides of this situation and so so
for me toxic masculinity is sort of
saying that at least for the best of the
best that I can interpret what it what
they're trying to say is that if you
take sort of traditional masculine
traits and then you take them to the
extreme well then it becomes negative
and well that's a true statement that's
actually a true statement so and it goes
back to the book dichotomy in leadership
is that if you take any positive trait
that a good leader can have and you take
it to an extreme then it can become a
negative so this is gonna happen with
any traits that any human being has if
you take a human trait to an extreme it
often becomes a negative so I mean a
clear one is if you're a good leader
then you need to be aggressive right
that's what you need to be and that
being said if you're too aggressive then
you're taking risks that are not
necessary and that's not gonna work how
good for you so that's why you you you
can't take the aggressive trait to the
extreme same thing with being ambitious
right because everyone you know a good
leader a good person a good kid is
ambitious but guess what if someone
becomes too ambitious then they're
stepping on other people so that they
can rise to the top and by the way that
that rise to the top will be short-lived
that's why it's not beneficial because
you might think well if you're ambitious
you step on people that you make it to
the top you're good to go it doesn't
work that way
cuz other people are gonna see that
you're stepping on them and they're
gonna rip you down so the group that
you're leading when you're stepping on
them will turn against you so yes you
should be ambitious but you can't be
extremely you can't take that to the
extreme being strong let's
being just physically strong that's
that's a great that's a great attribute
to have because because then you are
harder to bully right is it no one's
gonna push you around when you're a
strong individual that being said if you
go to you go too far with that and you
begin to abuse the strength that you
have to bully other people well then
that's not good and once again I'll tell
you if you do that the pack will turn
against you and take you down and so
there's all these traits that these are
considered sort of masculine traits like
being assertive right and and that is
definitely true if you're if you're a
good leader and I go from you know a man
to just be talking about leadership if
you're a good leader then you should be
assertive that being said if you're too
assertive then you don't listen anyone
elses ideas and and so that puts you at
a disadvantage because you're trying to
figure out everything for yourself and
you won't be able to do that so what
else what else for traditional masculine
traits oh to be less emotional right the
the the man is supposed to rely more on
logic than emotion and that certainly
makes sense as a leader because there's
no one that makes good decisions when
they're emotional now the dichotomy is
that if you are completely devoid of
emotions then you don't connect with
anyone you don't you don't have any
emotional connection with anyone and as
a leader if you don't have emotional
connections with people then you won't
truly be able to lead them you'll be
able to lead them on like a surface
level but you won't have the deep
connection that forms a solid bond
inside of a team you won't have that and
so the list of these traits it's it goes
on and on and and like I said these are
sort of these traditional masculine
traits and if you take them to the
extreme then they become negative oh and
also you've got to remember that it's
not just one extreme there's the other
there's the opposite extreme as well and
if you go in the opposite direction to
the extreme then that's equal
bad so if you've got a leader that's
hyper aggressive right we don't want
that but at the same time we don't want
a leader that's a pushover just like we
don't want someone that's overly
assertive right if you're if you're
overly assertive then you're not
listening to anyone else but at the same
time if you go in the other direction to
the other extreme then you've got
someone that's scared to speak up so
that's not good either and then talking
about the emotional thing again like we
don't want a leader that's completely
devoid of emotions but at the same time
you don't want a leader that's overly
emotional and is unstable and not able
to think logically and clearly so these
things these things need to be balanced
that's what they need to be they need to
be balanced in leaders they need to be
balanced in men and the fact that matter
is is that all these traits are equally
positive for women and they also need to
be balanced with women as well so to me
this idea of toxic masculinity is just
reflective of taking any human traits to
an extreme male or female doesn't matter
if you if you don't properly balance the
dichotomy of these traits that human
beings have you'll be out of balance and
will be a bad thing so try and stay
balanced that is to me the best solution
to these types of issues all right next
question is from white belt MMA s I have
no idea what that means but I'm glad you
have the white belt attitude that's a
good attitude to have what our Jacko's
experiences with cold or heat therapy
cold showers ice baths saunas etc okay
I'm definitely a believer in contrast
baths if you know what that is
contrast baths are going from hot to
cold I mean I like them both
individually but hot to cold I
definitely I had a I had a situation
that unfolded for me that really sent it
home I was I was at San Clemente Island
which is a little training site off the
coast of Southern California and on that
island that there's a hill called Frog
Hill and when you're going through basic
SEAL training
you run up that hill before every meal
and sometimes you carry things on your
back or whatever but it's a really steep
hill and it takes a few minutes to climb
up and it burns you out pretty good so
anyways I was out there for I wasn't
going through SEAL training but I was
out there doing some training with some
other troops and so while I was out
there I decided you know I'm just gonna
run frog Hill every day for every meal
just like we did in bud snow just trying
to stay hard and then I all I was out
there and this was probably ten years
ago or something like that maybe 12
years ago
I don't know but late late 2009
something like that and while I was out
there I also was working out hard you
know and I did this this CrossFit
workout this CrossFit workout which is
called Cal soo and and this this workout
is named after a guy while it's named
after a guy whose name was Cal suebob
Cal soo who was an all-american football
player for the University of Oklahoma
and then he played for the Buffalo Bills
in the 1968 season he was the Rookie of
the Year and after that season he went
and did his time in the army because he
had gone through I guess I'm an ROTC
scholarship and had an ROTC obligation
to the army and so he went in the army
to serve his time he went to the hundred
and first Airborne Division and deployed
to Vietnam and he was killed in action
and so this this work out like the man
himself is a is a tough workout tough
man tough workout in fact I'd say it a
little bit harder than tough it's
actually a pretty brutal workout and
here's the workout if you want to try
this
it's psycho every minute on the minute
so every minute you do five burpees and
then you do as many thrusters as you can
with 135 pounds and thruster is
basically a front squat and then push
press so you do that so you do every
minute you do five
and then you do max thrusters with 135
pounds and you keep doing this over and
over again until you get to a hundred
total thrusters and it is like a
complete soul-crushing leg destroyer of
a workout and anyways I did that work
out and plus I was running frog hills so
my legs were pretty much just completely
annihilated and then I was supposed to
be flying back to Coronado to where I
was working at the time the training
command out on the west coast I was
flying back there I was supposed to fly
back at in the middle that like for
lunch but our training ended I ended up
getting the first flight back from San
Clemente Island it was like 6 o'clock in
the morning and when I got back the
Master Chief
so I was the I was the officer in charge
of trade it at the time in the Master
Chief who was a who was kind of a runner
type guy and he picked me up from the
airport he's like hey man we're doing a
we're doing a command PT today which
means we're all gonna work out and do
physical training together and I'm like
oh cool you know cuz it's sort of you
know I'm the I'm the I'm the officer in
charge so if we're having command PT
then I should do it and he goes ok great
it's a you know we're doing a run and
we're doing a run down this there's a
lake and in San Diego and it's it's got
a trail around it it's like a seven or
eight mile or something like that but
there's it's got a lot lots of little
these little hills so cool you know I
already signed up for it so we get we
get we go and we go to do this run and
my legs are already crushed when I start
this run and then I end up racing with
one of my buddies who who's actually a
better runner than I am and but I'm
giving it everything I got to to hang
with him and I hang with him until
probably the last I don't know mile got
back from the lake went to the team and
when I got back to the training command
I went into our physical therapy guys
and I said hey man I just annihilated my
legs and I've been annihilating for like
five straight days what do you got
and
the guy that worked there who is a
awesome guy named Jason he said hey to
contrast baths and look what's that he
hot-cold hot-cold hot-cold so anyways he
put me in this protocol for ice bath to
the to the whirlpool the hot whirlpool
which is scolding hot
anyways I did the protocol I think it
was like five minutes five minutes four
minutes four minutes three minutes three
minutes two minutes two minutes one way
to one of it and I am not kidding when I
got done with that I was probably 60%
recovered just from that so do I believe
in Kolding he therapy yes I have a
Jacuzzi at my house and I have a nice
bath at my house so I believe in him
they work be careful if you ever do that
workout it hurts
next question what is one piece of
advice you'd give a man who's on the
brink of finishing it all tonight so you
know this is one of those questions that
comes across from time to time when
people are feeling like they have
reached the point where they cannot go
on anymore and so this is from anonymous
and I'll tell you right now what I'm
gonna tell you is number one okay we're
gonna wait until tomorrow and then and
so this is gonna sound like I guess like
a cop out of an answer or like a week
answer but then what you do is you
actually go and get some professional
help from someone and and and the reason
that I'm saying that is because I only
just recently kind of put this together
it is the fact that I didn't know
anything about psychologists and
psychology I thought that they were just
kind of weird people that would tell you
some mumbo-jumbo
stuff I didn't really understand it I
didn't know anything about it and I had
I had Jordan Peterson on my podcast and
we were talking about a bunch of
different subjects and he was talking
about how Houston I think he was talking
about how he would get people to
overcome fear of needles and he went
through this thing and what he explained
was called exposure therapy and I didn't
know what it was but it made perfect
sense to me and then as he was
explaining it I realized what he was
explaining was this methodology of
exposure therapy and that methodology is
the exact methodology that I had used in
the first way the warrior kid book to
teach this young kid mark to overcome
his fear of water so I just kind of used
instinctively something that I'd used
with my kids when they were afraid of
something I would expose them to it a
little bit a little bit a little bit a
little bit and then over time they would
not be afraid of it anymore
and so it's something that I had used
but but when Jordan Peterson who's a
clinical psychologist talked about it
this is an actual psychological
procedure and and that's when I started
to kind of make this connection is is
the fact that psychologists what they
are is they're basically like mechanics
they're like car mechanics but they're
mechanics for your brain or your mind or
whatever your thoughts because your
brain or your mind your thoughts can
have problems just like your car can
have a problem and what psychologists
know how to do just like a mechanic
knows how to do is they know how to
assess the problem and then give you a
solution to the problem and I think the
fact that they're called psychologists
kind of threw me off for for my life and
if they would have been called something
that the term I've been calling him his
mind and mechanics so if you if you said
oh I got problem with my mind I'm gonna
go to the mechanic and have it get fixed
that that makes sense right there's no
mumbo-jumbo there the psychologists
learn about what type of symptoms there
are and then they figure out how to
solve those and they learn techniques
and and procedures and protocols so that
so it's real is what I'm saying so so to
you anonymous
that asks this question you need them
you need a mind mechanic you know you
got an issue going on in there and you
got to get someone that knows how to
identify diagnose what the problem is
and then give you a solution to it so
hang in there go get some help that
that's what you need a professional help
I'm not a mind mechanic I'm not a
psychologist but there are people that
actually know how to help you and so go
get some go get some professional help
that's that's what you need another
thing I mean you know Tim came on my
podcast it's its podcast number 50 and
you know it's it's a crazy thing and a
lot of people they either don't know
this or they haven't heard about it or
it's easy to forget that tim was you
know when he was in college he not only
contemplated committing suicide but he
actually planned to commit suicide and
so when he came on my podcast we went
deep on that and we talked through it
and so if you're in that situation you
know Tim's a great example
you know it's he's a he's a was doing
great you know from the outside you know
he was going to an Ivy League school and
you know things were you would look from
the outside and say oh this guy's got
nothing to worry about his life is set
but on the inside you know he was in a
really rough place and in a place that
was so rough that he was thinking that
maybe he didn't want to continue on so
take a listen to that one you can hear
some of the things that Tim did and
continues to do to maintain a positive
attitude about where he's at and then
man go and get some professional help
because there's there's darkness out
there and sometimes that that darkness
in the world that surrounds your head
but you can get out of it man
good luck brother the next question is
also from anonymous one is a
step-by-step guide for building
discipline for someone who has little to
none of it I'll keep this one short I
answer this question a lot before you go
to bed make a list of the things that
you need to do tomorrow
so whatever those things are you make
you write them down work out you're
going to do you know this project or
that project you need this task or that
ask whatever they are you write them
down and then you set your alarm clock
and you said it earlier than you
normally would
okay look people get hung up because I
wake up at 4:30 that's just when I get
up you figure out when it's good for you
to get up make it a little bit earlier
like an hour earlier or a half hour
earlier than you normally would set your
alarm clock then go to sleep then when
your alarm clock goes off get just get
up get up no don't think about it don't
rationalize anything no snooze button no
just five more minutes just get up when
your alarm clock goes off put on your
workout clothes which you should have
laid out the night before I should have
said that to brush your teeth and go
work out get that done then shower pull
out the list that you made and attack
that list and get everything on that
list done that's what you do and then
the next day do the same thing and the
day after that do the same thing and
then imagine what your life is going to
be like in a week after a week of doing
that or after a month of doing that or
after three months of doing that or
after a year of doing that you're gonna
be in a totally different place if you
just do the things that you know you're
supposed to do every day you'll be in a
totally different place now
will the discipline get easier over time
we look it easier doesn't matter does it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if it's easy hard you
don't think about it you don't consider
that just just do what you're supposed
to do and then just stay on the path
because even though it might not get
easier
the rewards are going to grow and you'll
realize that the discipline you are
imposing into your life is making your
life better and giving you more freedom
the question 12 how do you build mental
toughness and resilience the answer is
you actually already have it you are a
human being and human beings can survive
the most insane adversity that you can
imagine I talked about it on my podcast
all the time these these people that go
through these atrocities or go through
these insane combat situations or get
put into prison camps they're not
superheroes
they're people they're normal people
that got drafted or that signed up after
Pearl
or that got recalled when the Korean War
kicked off or or got sent to Vietnam
because it was either that or go to jail
they're normal people and they have the
mental toughness and resilience and so
do you now you want to help reveal it
cool do some hard things do some mental
and some physical challenges that row
that require you to push yourself harder
get some
that's fine that'll reveal some of that
mental toughness but you have it and as
I said in Tim's book tools of Titan's if
you want to be tough be tougher don't
need to meditate on it just be tougher
you already have it next question if he
had not been in the military what would
he have done instead right if I was in
the military if I couldn't join the
military likely would have been probably
a policeman or a firefighter I think I
have a pretty inherent sense of duty
some patriotic feeling to serve and and
you know straight up I also like some
kind of like level of danger and I like
to take some level of risks and I feel
good about those they make me feel make
me feel alive and I like physical work I
like doing things like I like physically
moving around and getting things done
and making things happen and I like I
actually like high-stress situations so
I I enjoy mayhem and chaos and it's
where and when I say I enjoy him that
doesn't mean I'm about seeking him every
day but when they hit me that's where I
feel like I'm in my I mean I'm utilizing
the best of my natural capabilities
because I'm I'm calm under pressure I
stay relaxed I stay detached I can look
at like complex problems and kind of
simplify them well so I like being in
those situations so that's why I think
either one of those jobs probably would
have been what I would end up doing next
question is from Zak V my five-year-old
son has been doing jiu-jitsu for two
weeks now and he's not aggressive how do
you teach someone to turn on aggression
so
Zach bro your kid is 5 - do not worry
about your kids aggression level at this
age in fact what you need to do is be
happy that he hasn't hyper aggressive
kid that is slapping other kids around
and can't get along with other kids
that's a problem so don't worry about
this it's no factor and I've not only if
I brought my kids up but I've seen I
would say hundreds of kids go through
jiu-jitsu in their life and you don't
need to worry about this you don't need
to worry about trying them to teach them
to turn on their aggression in fact
instead of teaching them to turn on this
aggression I would teach him how to be
nice and how to play guitar and how to
be respectful and polite to other people
that's what I would would teach him
because when he turns 14 you're gonna
have to do everything in your power to
rein that aggression in that's gonna
come so you don't need to egg it on
it'll be there now if it's not there the
whether or not he ends up being
aggressive it is still one of the best
gifts that you can give him is given
jiu-jitsu but let me tell you what it do
please don't ruin it for him don't ruin
jiu-jitsu for him the best way to make
him good at jiu-jitsu is actually by
making it fun for him he's 5 years old
you want to make it fun I failed to do
that with my older daughters we might
older daughters I pushed them too hard I
was forcing it down their throat I was
making them train 6 days a week
ghee no ghee striking making him compete
and when I did make him compete I put
them in there against older kids and
heavier kids the kids that were better
than them and they'd get beat and I
thought of course in my mind I thought I
was like being an awesome dad because I
was making them super tough oh you know
what you're oh you're six years old cool
and put you against a nine year old girl
who is outweighs you by 22 pounds and
you're gonna get destroyed but you know
what it's gonna be good for your
character it's gonna make you tough
that's what that's what my idiot mind
was thinking and what I actually ended
up doing was making them not like
jiu-jitsu so don't do that to your son
what you want to do is you want to make
it fun and you want to find a school
where it's fun and you know what even
that's no guarantee cuz your kid may not
loved you Jitsu but at least if it's fun
he's gonna learn it
but but yeah I'm sorry to break the news
to you that you can't make your kid love
jujitsu you you can make it part of his
life but he's this isn't I'm sorry again
to break the news to you but your son is
an individual human being and you know I
got four kids and all my kids are great
kids and I can tell you this and this is
a hard fact for parents to realize it
was a hard fact for me to realize your
kids are not going to be what you want
them to be and case in point I asked I
asked this question to people all the
time I say are you what your parents
want you to wanted you to be everyone
says no who grows up and becomes exactly
what their parents wanted them to be no
one so the chances of you getting your
kid to be exactly the person you want
him to be the chances of that are zero
he's not gonna be who you want them to
be so what you do a matter of fact if
you if the more you try and conform him
into being what you wanted to be the
more you try and box him in the more he
is going to resent it the more he's
gonna push back against you so don't do
that don't try and don't try and box
them in be supportive make it fun now
I'm not saying you'd let kids do
whatever you want cuz you don't do that
you get you put them you give them
discipline you give them a box that they
need to stand and then you show them the
path but you don't put a dagger in their
back and force them to walk down it you
let them find their own way down the
path because they'll understand it
better and they'll be better people next
question you have started multiple
companies and businesses and you were on
since you were first on Tim's podcasts
over three years ago they all seem to be
doing great how do you do that yeah so I
have started a bunch of businesses and
they all seem to be doing really well
and certainly stoked on that
as far as how do I do that I would say
two major things and the first thing
that I would say is that I get involved
in businesses that are related to things
that I know about that I understand so
like the first business that I ever had
was an MMA gym I still have it it's
called victory MMA and we changed Jitsu
and and boxing wrestling without all
that stuff but the reason I started this
gym is because it's something that I
knew and understood we've been I've been
trying to in jiu-jitsu for a long time
and been training MMA fighters for a
long time and so this is something that
I knew and understood so we started gym
the the second real business that I
started was echelon front which is the
consulting company that had with my
brother Leif babban and a bunch of other
guys we have on the team now but again I
started that company was like this is
something that I knew and understood
we're teaching people leadership and
teaching leadership is exactly what I
was doing my last few years in the SEAL
Teams so I started a company that really
that was based directly around something
that I knew something that Lafe knew and
now when we bring other guys on the team
it's something that everyone knows and
understands so that was kind of evidence
it was it was a very clear that that's
something that I had the capability and
understanding of I guess the next one
down the list would be when a mighty the
jackal white tee which this is something
that it was actually with Tim I was with
Tim and Tim talked about it all the
first time I was on his podcast and it
was just like a little funny statement
he said and and then people kept asking
me you know what's the T what's the T
was the T so I just started you know
making the T and getting out there and
people were stoked on it and so there
you go that's something that I knew and
I knew that I liked it and started
making it and then you know that kind of
led to the rest of the supplements that
I make because I like certain I like to
take certain things and and I want to
take things that I know things that I
trust and things that I actually use and
so that's what I did made stuff that
tasted good that worked well and there
you go
and and then along the way
you know I got involved with with origin
main which is a which is a company up in
Maine which is manufacturing apparel
right here in America in Maine and you
know that was really more than anything
else because I didn't really have a
background in that but what happened was
I got I saw I saw a really kind of a
perfect storm brewing this this guy that
I had seen videos of on the internet
from origin he's the he was the founder
of origin he's gotta name Pete Roberts
and the thee had these videos on YouTube
and he's a jujitsu guy and he he wanted
to make keys he wanted to make keys in
America and there was no making keys in
America in a matter of fact he found out
that there was no one making the
material to make keys in America so
we're making the fabric to make keys in
America so he went on this kind of like
psycho quest to try and make that happen
and he had these videos of himself up in
Maine and him and his buddies pulling
these these the actually a loom is it's
not these it's one loom he went and
found a rusty old loom abandoned loom in
an abandoned Factory in Lewiston Maine
and they you know he pulled it out of
this factory and brought it back to his
place where he had built a factory built
a timber factory in the middle of the
woods in Maine and put this loom in
there and hired a guy that used to work
on these looms and they got that thing
running and he was up there making these
american-made geese and the the problem
was he was the problem was he was in
Maine and he was you know didn't really
he didn't have much reach and so I
reached out to him a couple times and
eventually got in touch with him and and
we were able to you know I kind of had
reach and and had people to talk to and
way a way to spread the word and then he
had the knowledge you know that he
gained to to start making apparel and
all that stuff and so that's what we're
doing so I just want to do one to help
him make America make again make America
make again you know that it
I'm from New England and when you see
the abandoned factories it's it's a it's
a horrible
it's a horrible sight and so for us to
be up there to have that company to be
breathing life back into an industry
that had been left for dead and to now
be making Gea's and making rash guards
and and other athletic apparel and we we
just came out with jeans because what's
more American than didn't damn blue
jeans so you know I said hey Pete well
actually what I said to Pete was I said
hey Pete how many people do you know
that dude jiu-jitsu and Pete said oh you
know I probably 100 I said how many
people do you know that have jeans and I
was standing in the airport at the time
and I said 80% of the people I'm looking
at right now we're wearing jeans
let's make jeans and even I'm not
wearing a gay pants right now I'm
wearing jeans so we started making jeans
now we're making boots so we'll make
everything so that's that's what
happened there and and then the last one
I guess the most recent company is the
is the publishing company is is jaakko
publishing and that one so that one's a
little bit more of a interesting
situation I had written another kid's
book called Mikey and the Dragons and
and this book I was super stoked on it I
finished it in August and I talked to my
publisher and I said hey you know I've
got this new kids book and I just want
to get it out by Christmas cuz I want
and the book is about a little kid that
learns how to overcome fear and it's a
rhyming story and has amazing pictures
in it that one of my buddies drew and so
I was just this really great book when I
read it to my youngest daughter you know
she was just blown away by it my wife
actually reaction was did you actually
write that so I thought that was a
really good compliment she didn't
actually believe I was capable of doing
it so anyways I was super stoked and got
this and and I said to my publisher I
said hey you know I want this book to
come out by Christmas and this was in
August and they said well no that's not
not possible and I said well no please
and they said well nothing we can't do
it and I said no seriously I really
wanted out by then
and then they said there's no scenario
where this book comes out by Christmas
and I said watch this so I had a friend
that you know a friend that she had was
in the publishing business and I said
hey can you help me make this happen and
she said let's do it and so started the
publishing company and book came out in
November Mikey and the Dragons and now I
have a publishing company I got another
couple books in the works for the for
the publishing company from not just me
but I got another couple authors that
I'm working with that are putting books
together that are awesome so there you
go so all those things are saying all
those different businesses as I said
like these are all things that I kind of
know and understand and that's that's
I'd say part one of me figuring out what
businesses I want to do and then the
second part the second part is that I
actually follow my own leadership
principles that's the the principles
that I teach I utilize them myself and I
cover move I keep things simple I
prioritize and execute I implement
decentralized command and that's a
really big one because you know I've got
people I've got people on my teams that
they damn decentralized command they
know what my vision is and they are free
to go out there and make it happen to
the best of their ability and if they
need support they come back to me if
they need guidance they come back to me
and if they don't then they're out there
crushing it so that's that's what
happens they're making these things
happen and I'm kind of looking up and
out and to see what's next down the line
and see what else we can get into so
yeah try and get involved in what you
know and understand and then follow the
fundamental leadership principles
fundamental combat leadership principles
one more question here this is from
Oliver and he says what is your biggest
failure well for me this is pretty
straightforward pretty straightforward
answer when I was in the Navy when I was
in the SEAL Teams my last tour
was in Iraq I was the commander of SEAL
team 3 tasking a bruiser
we fought in the Battle of Ramadi in the
summer of 2006 we did our job well we
had the honor of supporting these
soldiers and Marines from the 1st
Brigade 1st Armored Division and we all
fought together to defeat the brutal
insurgents that were there and it was a
very tough battlefield it was a tough
fight it was an honor to serve alongside
those soldiers and Marines and the task
unit that I was in charge of really
performed exceptionally day after day
after day and in the end victory was
achieved in the city of Ramadi and
Ramadi was liberated from the sadistic
insurgents that had reigned there the
people were allowed to return to their
normal lives but I did not bring home
all my men then that's that so
thanks to everyone for listening thanks
to Tim for having me on and for
everything you've done to help me out I
started my podcast because of Tim and
and and Jill Rogan as well and Jill
Rogen heard me because of Tim in the
first place so thanks to Tim if you want
to hear anything else from me I'm on
Twitter and I'm on Instagram and I'm on
Facebook at Chaco willing my podcast is
called jaakko podcasts it's wherever you
get your podcasts the books that I've
written are on Amazon and other places
books are sold my clothes are on Jocko
store calm my supplements red orange in
Maine calm my consulting companies
echelon front calm its Ilana comms for
you anyways that's all I've got
again thanks to Tim for having me on and
thanks to everyone that is listening to
this thanks for spreading the word
thanks for of course going out there and
getting after it this is Jacques a will
Inc no further traffic oh hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun before the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric
as I do it could include favorite
articles that I have read and that I've
shared with my close friends for
instance and it's very short it's just a
little tiny bite of goodness before you
head off for the weekend so if you want
to receive that check it out just go to
4-hour workweek dot-com that's 4-hour
workweek comm all spelled out and just
drop in your email and you will get the
very next one and if you sign up I hope
you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LinkedIn if you're looking for a job
know where to look is the first step
towards finding the right fit
LinkedIn has more than 20 million job
postings from software engineer to
robotics engineer project manager to HR
manager or associate attorney to
associate veterinarian there's something
for everybody
they have everything it also has one of
the largest communities to help you
connect and network with people who can
open doors for you give you valuable
career advice help you learn new skills
and introduce you to people and
companies and organizations that are
hiring companies or organizations that
are looking for exactly your skill set
and no matter where you are in your
career whether you're just starting out
wondering what to do
switching to a new type of role or
completely starting over and no matter
what job you're looking for there are
people on LinkedIn who can help you find
it
with more than 20 million jobs posted
there's a good chance that LinkedIn has
exactly what you're looking for you just
have to check it out so find the job
meant for you at LinkedIn comm forward
slash jobs again that's linkedin.com for
slash jobs this episode is brought to
you by LegalZoom which more than 2
million Americans have used to help
start their businesses past guests even
such as wealth wordpress lead developer
CEO of automatic matt mullenweg now
valued at more than a billion dollars
have used LegalZoom to help with their
business needs specifically in his case
to form his company but LegalZoom isn't
just for launching your business their
services include everything from helping
you to manage changing tax laws
reviewing contracts creating NDA's
non-disclosure agreements important
stuff handling lease agreements and
assisting with really any other legal
challenge hurdle inconvenience that
typically takes time and effort away
from running your business the best part
is that you won't get charged by the
hour
because LegalZoom isn't a law firm so
they won't be running the clock up and
spinning circles just to raise your bill
instead they just ask you to pay one low
upfront price for whatever it is that
you're looking to get ala carte style so
visit legalzoom.com and check out their
business section for all of their
services and if you want special savings
that's the terminology and the copy that
they suggest I don't know what the
special savings is folks but it's
titillating if you want special savings
enter promo code Tim T I am at checkout
capital T lowercase I am again take a
peek legalzoom.com and enter promo code
to him